have you ever wondered if Pi actually
makes any sense
Pi is defined as the ratio of a circle's
circumference to its diameter
but how do we know this is the same
ratio for all circles
in two different circles inscribe
regular polygons with n sides each
since the regular polygons are similar
their perimeters are in the same ratio
as their radii
we can now increment the number of sides
in both polygons indefinitely
each perimeter approaches its circle
circumference
rearranging and dividing by two shows
the ratio of each circle's circumference
to its diameter is the same and we call
that ratio pi
so Pi actually is a constant and what
you were taught does make sense